[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
as Xander mentioned I'm Peter Schwartz I
have the privilege of being a trustee of
long now and Stuart is tonight at Ted
we're having a much more much better
time here than I think Stuart is
probably down to Ted we've got a much
more interesting speaker than they do
III I have a really a great privilege as
many of you know I have been interested
in the subject of climate change for a
long time and particularly how climate
change affects human societies and in
fact my first climate study was back in
1977 when the issue was global cooling
and we did our study just as the world
was turning we were at a tipping point
when the world started warming again it
had warmed from in 1895 roughly till
about 1960 and then cooled until about
75 big question was were we headed into
another Little Ice Age were we headed
for another much colder future well it
turned out no we weren't we were just
going in a new direction which is the
direction we're going in now but that
began to lead me to interesting
questions about where the climate was
going but the truth is that one of the
things I didn't really understand was
how human societies had in fact wrestled
with this issue many times in the past
and then a number of years ago in the
the pursuit of the books for the gbn
book club I happened to read a book
called the little ice age by Brian Fagan
and discovered in fact that at least one
person had been exploring over a very
long period of time how in fact in fact
for four hundred thousand years and
particularly the last few thousand years
how climate and society have interacted
how people have adapted to climate
change and that man of course was Brian
Fagan Brian recently retired as a
professor at UC Berkeley Santa Barbara
from the anthropology department where
he studied he was a professor of
archaeology looking at the ancient
societies Brian's also it tells me a
serious sailor and that a lot of his
insights have come from his experiences
on the sea and those of us who have the
privilege of sailing know that it is a
very power
awful teacher and we share that
experience with Brian let me mention one
other thing before I hand over some of
you will know that last Friday we at gbn
published a new report on climate change
and national security if you're
interested in the subject you can go to
the gbn website it's available there and
it's raising some interesting questions
of where the climate is going in the
not-too-distant future and with that oh
yes our questions so that as you came in
you were given this little card on the
back is the space for questions we will
have people collecting questions is that
right during the course of the evening
bring them we'll bring them forward and
we will then pose a few questions to
Brian at the end of the evening over to
you good evening ladies and gentlemen I
must say I'm very impressed to see such
a huge audience in the new venue on a
Friday night the last lecture I gave was
at MIT and just before I went the
lecture there was a reception beforehand
and I heard two people saying are you
gonna go and hear Fagin and the other
guy said hell no I'm gonna go and have a
drink so if anyone wants to leave and
have a drink now's the moment it's a
great privilege to be here to talk about
something that there's been a strange
reluctance to talk about on the part of
archaeologists and historians and that
is climate change about 10 years ago I
embarked on a project which Stewart just
mentioned the write a book on the Little
Ice Age which was a period a very
unpredictable often colder climate from
about 1300 to 1860 AD and I wrote to a
very eminent historian and said because
I knew nothing about the literature can
you give me a few guides as to climate
change who's writing about it and he
wrote to me and said her nobody's
thought about that since at least 1970
he was wrong there were all sorts of
people looking at it but they weren't
looking at it so much from the very long
view they were looking at
more from the perspective of detail for
example a remarkable French historian
Emmanuel Lyle Adderley wrote a book on
the dates of wine harvests because each
fall the authorities and different
villages would decide on the day of the
harvest and if you have good rains and
good weather the harvest is early if you
have poor weather the harvest is late
and they have measured climate change
over many centuries since then and there
are historians out now who are making
their living studying wine harvests but
it's a very very specialized world and
what I want to do this evening is take a
wide view and a long view because
another thing in his great wisdom that
Laroy laterally he did and I wish I
admit him he must have been lovely
he described two types of historians in
classically French clothes Lavar as it
were the parachutists who parachute
gently to earth and survey the broad
landscape of history and then as it were
the lava truffle hunters who grabbed in
the soil and fascinate themselves with
minut detail that's archaeologists for
you what I want to do today is to be a
parachutist and I want to start by
taking you to the middle Zambezi Valley
in Africa and I want you to imagine
before the days are getting hotter and
hotter and stickier and stickier and day
after day the Sun shines out of a brazen
sky dust rising from the ground which is
completely parched and the men and women
are out there hoeing the fields and
clearing the brush they burn the brush
let it fall on the fields to fertilize
and then every day it gets hotter and
hotter think a hundred and five degrees
and in the middle of the day people sit
in the shelter of the houses and do not
move if you move a finger you sweat it's
that hot and it gets hotter and hotter
and every afternoon massive black clouds
mount in the western horizon and every
day they get closer and closer and you
can feel the tension and tempers flare
and then one day the clouds come close
and there are cracks of thunder and a
few raindrops and then the deluge comes
and you can feel the tension evaporate
out of the ground as the wind the
temperature falls by about 20 degrees
and when the rain is gone they make a
decision to plant and they plant and
then they wait and they wait and they
wait and if they're lucky it rains but a
lot of the time it doesn't Lane and they
wait and the crops wither in the fields
or it rains five miles away and their
neighbors have Ray have danced our crops
and they do not and all too often among
subsistence farmers the fate is dropped
this is a lecture about among other
things drought but it's also about some
realities of ancient climate in the long
term we have in many senses been there
before this is a graph from an ice core
dug near the Vostok and Arctic's station
in Antarctica it covers four hundred
thousand years
and it shows the co2 levels high with
the cold low with the warm look at the
fluctuation right up till today the
world's climate over the last seven
hundred and eighty thousand years has
been in a transition from warm to cold
for or cold to warm for over 75% of the
time the longest period of relatively
stable climate has been since the last
ice age ended 15,000 years ago there is
ladies and gentlemen only one way you
can look at climate and that is in the
long haul and from my point of view you
can talk as much as you like about
global warming and all the rest but in
the final analysis the most important
thing to us is the impact of it on
people and that's the perspective I'm
gonna give you this evening about 15
thousand years ago warming began it was
at first hesitant there were
considerable fluctuations but warming
happened very very rapidly people don't
realize firstly how few people the were
in the world 15,000 years ago and
secondly how different the world was
global sea levels were 300 feet lower
than they are today
huge ice sheets covered North America
much of Scandinavia and the Alps most of
Central Europe right across the Siberia
was treeless steppe tundra but as the
warming happened the sea levels rose
Alaska was severed from Siberia England
was no longer part of the continent
thank goodness
the continental shelves of Southeast
Asia and elsewhere went under the ocean
and the vegetation zones changed
dramatically but and here is our first
lesson from the past it wasn't all
warming in Southwest Asia at the end of
the Ice Age the environment was wetter
and much better watered than it is today
today's degradation of course in part is
due to intensive herding of animals but
this strip you can see there in dark was
a strip of extremely nice mixed oak
woodland which every fall yielded
enormous harvests of acorns pecans and
other edible plants so much so that in
this area the hunter-gatherers who could
live there settle down and lived in
permanent settlements something that is
almost unheard of for hunter-gatherers
except in areas of exceptional resource
abundance like this but then on the
other side of the world a really
dramatic event occurred in northern
candor ice sheets were retreating across
what is now Canada in the height of the
ice age they had extended right down to
the Great Lakes and as they were treated
they formed a huge and there you can see
it in black glacial lake here's a large
amount of it much of it is in Lake
Winnipeg today and suddenly about 11,000
BC that Lake burst its banks and
billions of litres of water flowed fresh
water beautifully fresh water
load into the North Atlantic and
cascaded across the surface of the salty
ocean the effect was to shut down at
least partially the Gulf Stream which
bought warm temperatures to Europe and
with Anna generation they think much of
Europe was plunged back into near
glacial conditions now in Europe there
was a sparse population of reindeer
hunters who simply adjusted to the
conditions by moving but in Southwest
Asia where the oak forests were thick
and people were living in permanent
villages the situation was very
different as the drought intensified and
I'm talking here about a thousand year
drought period not twenty years the
forests were treated or thinned out the
people then turned to wild plant foods
grasses but whose grasses became rarer
and in a fascinating archaeological site
in Syria they have used samples of seeds
to show that the people adapted by
firstly eating a much wider range of
plant foods and secondly by beginning to
plant seeds deliberately trying to
expand the range the availability of
edible grasses they were desperately
trying to preserve their traditional
hunter-gatherer life way but instead
genetic changes in the crops were such
that they became farmers within a few
generations within a thousand years some
of these farmers were living walled
towns like the one of Jericho here the
economies spread rapidly
people were now settled in villages and
anchored to their lands and when you
anchor to your lands your whole dynamic
changes imagine that this is a village
and we are living in it cheek by jowl in
small houses built of mud brick with
courtyards and narrow alleyways and flat
roofs and during the long winter tempers
flare you cannot move so you have to
develop entirely new relationships with
people and you have to develop
relationships with neighboring villages
so if your crops fail your relatives can
bail you out and you have an entirely
new relationship to with the land
because you are very very vulnerable now
because you can't move away from your
fields because your fields feed you and
you've cleared the land and the wild
plant foods are no longer available and
what becomes terribly important are your
ancestors because life is governed by
the eternal cycle of the seasons spring
with the ploughing and the planting
summer with the growth and the adulthood
fall the harvest and winter death just
like human existence and farmers assumed
that their lives would continue the same
their long view of humanity was that it
would be the same and that we would live
like our ancestors did and future
generations would live like we did and
this is a very adaptable way to live if
you are a subsistence farmer because you
depend on each other and you depend on
the ancestors why the ancestors because
the ancestors are you spiritually we've
gone to the supernatural world who are
people you knew who are intermediaries
to the spiritual world who are the
guardians of the land and I'll never
forget in Africa in the gained in the
Zambezi Valley
night after night hearing the drums beat
and they were beat from dusk until dawn
they would beat when somebody died when
they would chase the spirit of that
person into the bush to wander for a
year and then after a year they would
drum again and they would summon the
spirit back to become one of the revered
ancestors and I vividly remember once
going to a village meeting to get
permission to dig a hole in an
archaeological site and it was just like
a board meeting here and the village
elders were there but before we can
began the village spirit medium stood up
and invoked the ancestors a.m. Guam some
Aguayo McGuire and clapped his hands to
get the blessing of the ancestors on the
enterprise so we dug with the blessing
of the ancestors they were the guardians
of the land I've gone on rather long
about this because it's very important
to realize that enormous numbers of
people in today's world are living at
the subsistence level often in marginal
lands and they are the hidden elephants
in the room when we talk about the long
future of climate change people have
adjusted to climate crises of various
sorts for thousands of years I could
give you example after example the one
I'm gonna give you though is one from
ancient Egypt
you can't give a lecture on archeology
without talking about Egypt people get
upset if you don't talk about it 3,000
years ago ancient Egyptian civilization
came into being with the unification of
Egypt as a single linear kingdom along
the Nile and we embarked on the old
kingdom which was the first great period
of Egyptian civilization marked of
course by
orgy of pyramid-building no ladies and
gentlemen I am NOT going to talk about
pyramid power and its cosmic presence
I'm just saying that those were built by
pharaohs who used religious ideology to
perpetuate the notion that they were
gods on earth and that they were
infallible and one of the big sores that
every school T student reads visible is
the notion that ancient Egyptian
civilization was nourished by the floods
of the Nile every year in the summer the
flood would come up would water the land
and then the flood would recede and the
people would plant and there would be
plenty to eat an ancient Egyptian
civilization with all its panoply of
glory flourished for thousands of years
wrong you may not be aware of it but the
difference between a high and a low
flood on the Nile is a matter of a few
meters and Egypt was always vulnerable
to two things one was excessive floods
which would flood everything wipe out
entire villages do great destruction
destroy centuries of irrigation work in
a few days or just as bad drought
because the Nile is like an arrow shot
through the desert floodplain is fertile
if it is watered if it is not it is
desert and the Old Kingdom Pharaohs
preached that they were the great gods
and that they controlled the destiny of
the Nile they controlled the flood and
then in 21 80 BC just after a pharaoh
called Pepi the second died after
reigning for 67 years like ramses ii he
was long lived the nile flood
failed and there are graphic accounts of
how the Nile dried up in Upper Egypt
people could walk across the river there
was rioting people starved people
wandered aimlessly in search of food and
people turn to the Pharaoh and said food
please you've got it you're the God and
of course he didn't and Egypt collapsed
for a hundred years it collapsed into
small continuant parts and the people
who kept it going were the provincial
governors like this gentleman here who
ruled resolutely they knew their
villages and they shut their boundaries
they built dams they planted on sand
banks in the river they prevented people
moving they rationed food and the people
survived without the Pharaoh how do we
know this because their burial
inscriptions in their tombs have been
preserved and one of them a man called
Ketty saying I saved the people with my
bold actions just like a modern day
politician but he did and the lesson
from this was that resolute leadership
saved the day and in the final analysis
if you look at climate change in the
long term if you were a subsistence
farmer the thing that keeps you going is
not a central government it is the links
of your village your family your ties to
the land because that's where you're
least vulnerable there are innumerable
cases of climate change some of them
produced there volcanic eruptions as the
course is Vesuvius which wiped out
company at least twice or you can take
another example from the Andes this is
the Moche liver and the coast of Peru
some of the driest most arid land in the
world but fluid flow fertile river
valleys which are watered by mountain
runoff
from the Andes and he was here in the
last two thousand years that a series of
remarkable wealthy states arose based on
two things one was the harvest of
anchovies from the natural upwelling off
the Pacific coast caused by the north
flowing cold Humboldt Current and the
second was intensive irrigation
agriculture in the river valleys using
mountain runoff and the people who lived
there became real experts at water
conservation and the most famous of all
these societies which flourished during
the first millennium ad was a
civilization based on these pyramids
here which was called the mochi
basically it was a series of petty
kingdoms ruled by people who were are
called by archeologists warrior priests
an 8,400 a warrior priest or series of
them died and by a fortunate accident in
1989 these burials were recovered before
looters could get at them and from them
we have a portrait of the men who ruled
this society which is very informative
if you look at climate change this is
one of the Lords of Sipan in Peru he is
dressed this as a weapon of course in
his formal regalia I want you to imagine
the pyramid I just showed you
not a ruin but plastered and painted a
brilliant white with plazas underneath
and the plazas full of a crowd of people
drums are beating incense is flowing
people are chanting and then suddenly as
the Sun is setting there is silence
and everybody looks up to the tini
temple on the top of the mirror and
suddenly he appears and the Sun glitters
off his headdress he is the Living God
the living infallible God who controlled
the destiny of people now again I want
to come back to today's world we have
unless you're a reborn Christian an
enormous Li long perspective on human
existence 2 3 4 5 6 million years we
certainly have with the long life
expectancies we have a long generational
memory I once met an Irish archaeologist
whose grandfather had met a woman who
had seen the French land in Ireland in
1790 my I met last year a man who was in
his 90s who had heard Adolphe Hitler
speak in the flesh my great-grandfather
was in the Crimean War just for the
long-lived family the life expectancy of
the Moche was about 28 30 the life of a
medieval peasant in Europe 24 25 years
your whole perspective on life on
philosophy on climate change is totally
different
because has happened here
major Bell Nino's happen maybe once or
twice essentially and these men and
here's a brilliant portrait of one of
them on a pot preached we think that
they were the supreme gods they weren't
little
but look at the face look at the
arrogance look at the boldness of the
man he's looking into the distance he
was a guard and he knew it and society
was very rigid and the number of people
who had wealth who had power very smooth
small numbers of families and when a
major el nino hit this area and it did
huge hundred year floods because the
only news here bring rain combined with
some earthquakes combined with the
counter-current of El Nino which cut off
the anchovy officially literally
destroyed the fabric of that
civilization in a few days the warrior
priests regrouped but within two
centuries their society was gone it was
simply too rigid to adapt
what I'm talking about really and I'm
going to talk about more now is
subsistence farming I want to remind you
that even today enormous numbers of
humanity and this isn't us and the
hardest problem I have teaching students
and I'm very filled a couple of my
former students here this evening the
one thing I have always had a problem
teaching is not everybody buys food in
supermarkets you laugh but I'm deadly
serious they live from harvest to
harvest from day to day and they have a
life unimaginably different to ours
what governs that life the cycles of the
seasons
this is a gentleman called Hubert Lam he
looks it was wearing the classic dress
of a distinguished University professor
in Britain he was a lovely man he was a
meteorological detective his specialty
was the history of climate change over
the last four thousand years or so and
he did this back in the 60s when nobody
really thought about climate and
historians really ignored him he was one
of the great heroes and what he did was
take fragmentary historical records like
for example the diary of a country
priest logs from naval captain's records
of agricultural activity records of
vineyards and from this he said there
was perhaps a Medieval Warm Period a
period of somewhat warmer more stable
climate between about eighty eight
hundred and twelve hundred and he called
this the Medieval Warm Period it was a
time and this is very important to
realize and a lot of people don't
realize this that the whole of Europe
virtually at that time was in
subsistence farming and lived from one
harvest to the next this of course is a
Pieter Bruegel painting which paints a
very idyllic picture of a harvest in a
good year and by piecing this together
he produced some remarkable information
for example he pointed out that
vineyards flourished not only in Europe
but in Britain this is Gloucestershire
by the river seven beautiful country if
you haven't been there go there and try
the cheese I'm not joking it's wonderful
but in eleven thirty a monk William of
Malmesbury
travel through here and said words the
effect the wine here was wonderful and
it isn't too bitter it's not too sweet
and vineyards in England was so
productive and so good
they were exporting wine to France and
the French were bitching because the
market was being saturated with English
wine have you tasted English wine
actually somewhere it's pretty good but
in those days they were glaring wine in
central England today they're growing it
in the south and that's it but not only
that but they were growing cereal crops
in parts of Scandinavia even in Iceland
snow levels were higher than they are
today
so he defined very tentatively this guy
was a good scholar he said I think there
was a warm-up here I can't really pin it
down I think there was and it lasted
from AD 800 to 1250 higher snow lines
longer growing seasons which is very
important in much of Europe where cereal
crops can be tricky and during the
Little Ice Age when it got colder they
were slightly higher summer temperatures
and drier warm months which are very
good for glowing crops and wine was
grown in England and northern Germany
and this he said was followed by a
little Ice Age I love this picture and
the Little Ice Age people think of a
deep freeze in fact it was a period of
extremely volatile changeable climate
which included particularly in the 17th
century some pretty cold weather and
there is evidence which I'll show you in
a moment I will show you now and go back
that the Thames flooded and there's the
famous thing which every English school
student learns about of the parties on
the Thames which froze over the Thames
didn't freeze over after about 1750 one
of the reasons being they were building
bridges but it's the class
image of the Little Ice Age in fact the
Little Ice Age was very much more
volatile than that and it began in 1813
15 and this is where we get back to
subsistence farming in 1315 they planted
crops after Easter and almost
immediately after they planted them and
this was after a couple of centuries of
pretty good harvests and a lot of
expansion lot more people
it started to lane and it rained and it
Wayne and it rain by Christmas there was
hunger and for seven years it rained and
the crops fail between one and a half
and a 1.8 million people died as a
result of famine and particularly famine
related diseases as a result of these
seven years which gives you some idea of
the vulnerability of medieval Europeans
to climate change but if you look at
this on the long-term you're very much
looking at I have a limited picture what
Hubert Lam called church steeple
meteorology imagine a world like the
medieval world or think of the Norse
Vikings how would they know when a storm
was coming all they had was either the
view from the top of their mast all from
the touch of a church steeple which
meant they may be at the most would have
a day's warning of the weather that was
coming today we have computer models and
we have all this thing it is amazing
that people survived at all because the
great myth of the Medieval Warm Period
was that it was a warm period it wasn't
it was partially warm
because like all these things do in
academic life their Medieval Warm Period
became a finite period in history 800 to
1200 cubed lamb said it was the Medieval
Warm Period therefore it was the
Medieval Warm Period and it poured into
the literature but at the same time
unfortunately for us a revolution in
climatology has completely changed our
perceptions of how humans in the past
adapted to climate change ice cores tree
wings fossil pollens deep-sea cause Lake
holes and from this is a completely
different view of the Medieval Warm
Period and of course this whole thing
has got wrapped up in the controversies
over anthropogenic global if you look at
climate change in the long haul you
would dare accept the fact that humans
have adjusted to global warming again
and again if you look at the perspective
of four hundred thousand years now we've
got the conceptual and the scientific
tools to look at these changes much more
family and many of these changes are now
studied by what are called proxies
indirect indications treelings deep-sea
cores and so and here is the record
since pretty early on in the Medieval
Warm Period the temperature anomaly
minus and plus over the last thousand
years or more and notice that the black
line which is the instrument record only
goes back about a hundred and fifty
years before that it's all proxy and
look at all the different proxies levar
and notice the only thing that everyone
agrees on
it's a steady upward climb since 1860 I
don't think there's any reputable
scientist around over a few now who do
not believe that humanity has a major
stake to play in this and I just want to
say I am sick and tired of the
celebrated case of the hockey stick the
diagram which says this is like a hockey
stick and from there people say ah it
was warmer during the Medieval Warm
Period and there's been this endless
debate as to whether temperatures were
higher a thousand years ago or not
ladies and gentlemen it doesn't matter
a because before about a thousand AD
proxies still are very incomplete and
secondly it's academic because the
temperatures probably will lower and
what matters is we have warming it
doesn't matter how much this warming is
relative to a thousand years ago because
history ain't gonna repeat itself so I
think a lot of the debate about the
hockey stick is not interesting what is
however interesting is the benefits or
otherwise of the Medieval Warm Period as
I said Europe at the time was assistance
continent people lived from harvest to
harvest from year to year the crop
yields were astoundingly small compared
with today except near towns like London
where there was much more intensive
production of farms and as a result
hunger was on everybody's mind no farmer
went through life or his family without
suffering from at some point
malnutrition or hunger and as Hubert
lamb pointed out and people ignored the
Medieval Warm Period in fact was a pea
very volatile climate yes during 1100 to
about 1200 1300 there was a period of
relatively stable climbing and that was
the period when there was a huge growth
in medieval population but that didn't
alter the fact that most farming was
low-tech the plowing was done with
simple prong or moldboard plows the seed
was scattered and then they would drive
a horse or an ox towing a Harrow over
the strip farm the strip field to cover
the grain and you were completely at the
mercy of rainfall most years during the
eleventh and twelve hundreds the harvest
was pretty good but there were other
hazards too you would gather the harvest
you would stack it let it dry and hope
you would get it under cover before it
rotted over the Lane life was
unremittingly hard this famous painting
of a peasant woman by brothel she was
probably no longer not much older than
about 25 life expectancy on a Winchester
peasant in the estates in Winchester was
24 years the life of a medieval
fisherman was estimated at 28 if that
people lived with their cattle in very
unsanitary conditions and they lived by
the seasons imagine a society in which
all knowledge was transmitted from one
generation to the next almost entirely
verbally where life expectancy was short
where child mortalities were huge where
cattle diseases were endemic where
people had every parasite imaginable
were in the winter
everybody huddled around a fire and with
greatest luxuries to have a woollen
or somebody to sleep with it was a
brutal existence and under those
circumstances in Europe milder winters
and longer summers with a longer growing
season were an enormous economic boost
in a continent that was mostly
countryside it was a time however of
rapid growth of towns and cities like
London and Paris and a rapid population
growth and there was no question that
there is a tie between warmer climate
longer growing seasons more food
production and population growth and as
a result people expanded into the
forests we fly over Europe today or
you'll pound on a train you will see
these beautiful green countryside
industrial scale agriculture it's very
hard for people to imagine that even a
hundred years ago the appearance of the
European countryside was very different
because people were living still mainly
on small farms in medieval times there
were enormous tracts of um primordial
forests which had never been cleared
since the Ice Age and between about 1100
and 1300 about a third to half of
European forests were cut down and
burned down to acquire new agricultural
land some of this was encouraged by
Lords who encourage their peasants to
expand others by villagers who just
cleared forests others religious houses
did a lot of the clearance but in these
two centuries the landscape of Europe
was totally transformed but much of the
agriculture that resulted was done on
slopes and when the rains came in 1315
these slopes were heavily eroded much of
the soil was marginal
so people starve when their crops fail
just something that's happening today
and above all other sources of the
forest were lost game plants and timber
there was ten percent less rainfall
slightly higher temperatures and more
than half of Europe's forests vanished
the only place you could really see
primordial forests today is in Poland
let's look at some other long-term
consequences of the Medieval Warm Period
of Kirk Douglas and the Vikings how many
of you seen that movie what a little bit
audience who are ladies and gentlemen as
an ex professor I assign you to go to a
video store and see that appalling ly
bad movie it's all about warships orgies
battles Viking funerals and people with
trumpets it does the Vikings a gross
miss just Asst they were above all
consummate seamen and most of their
voyaging was done not in war long ships
but in boats like this Kano's merchant
vessels which sailed surprisingly well
which had elapsed reg house which flexed
with the waves and in these during the
Medieval Warm Period which was a period
when ice retreated from around Iceland
way north they ventured as far as
Iceland in 900 they of course went to
Greenland then they went up down the
Labrador and Newfoundland and very
interestingly they developed a
relationship with the inner witch in
Bath Finland with whom they traded iron
and it is thought that conditions in
North were so warm that some of that
Viking on may even have gone as far west
as the Bering Strait connections with
another world
so this was a favorable outcome when the
Little Ice Age came around 1250 up in
the North fair rapidly Greenland became
untenable to the Norse who lived on a
dairy economy and they abandoned it and
left it to the Inuit in the compass of
time available I am skipping over all
sorts of different subjects with
disgusting superficiality which is the
lack of a lecturer but I want to throw
another one at you this is gloopy er
horrendous the Atlantic heron the most
prolific of all fish they swarm in the
millions and every winter every spring
they gather in the North Atlantic north
of the North Sea and then as the summer
progresses they come down the east coast
of Scotland and England and spawn in the
seven North Sea and also all South
Sweden now what is not known is anything
about the ecology of herrings how
sensitive are they to cold water and
during the Medieval Warm Period that a
huge industry in headings developed now
the problem with a heading is it as a
very fatty flesh and this spoils in ours
the way to eat a herring is to catch it
and put it straight in the frying pan
yum yum yum but many evil people didn't
do that they had to salt them and
salting is an enormous ly difficult
process when you were talking about a
fish with fatty flesh and it was about
900 that somebody in Scandinavia
developed a way of salting fish in
barrels packing them in barrels salting
them in brine which was so effective
that you could ship these battles all
over Europe and a huge industry in
headings the
developed over this century these
centuries why did it develop partly out
of a need to feed the urban poor because
the greatest fear of any monarch in
those days when unrest in cities and the
second was to satisfy Christian doctrine
that you eat fish on Fridays you laugh
but this was a major industry and little
later centuries when the Newfoundland
card industry developed it was fuelled
almost entirely by the Catholic doctrine
did you eat fish on Fridays am I bored
in your war shall I continue okay so
there were some benefits looking back a
thousand years you can look at the
Medieval Warm Period two ways you can do
it like many historians do or
climatologists and just look at it like
this as a European phenomenon Whoopie a
time of prosperity of cathedrals of
forest clearance of peasants dancing in
the streets
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba but if you look at it
globally you get a very different
picture got a picture of drums not short
droughts but prolonged droughts
here hyper arid areas of the world and
the added areas it is in these areas
that the impact of warmer conditions
even slightly warm is greatest and a
good example is the Sahara or the
Ovation steps think of your lungs
provided they're not contaminated with
cigar smoke think of breathing in when
the rainfall gets higher the deserts or
semi-arid lands attract people and
animals why there was water well when he
gets drier it pushes them out to the
margins and this was an enormous leap
our felicity
over the long term and when you look at
modern anthropogenic warming we're
looking at greater warmth greater
droughts and more push out people to the
margins of added lands the same applies
to in northern China where even today
people are getting water supplies by
tapping ice caps and what is very
interesting there in recent years they
have studied coral wings old coral is
rather rare it's very difficult to find
but if you find it like tree wings it
gives you a proxy record of temperatures
and of El Nino events over large areas
of the Pacific some years ago a young
graduate student was sent on a research
vessel to Palmyra Atoll which is 300
miles southwest of Hawaii
this is nowhere and in the Pacific she
found a record of corals going back to
the Medieval Warm Period and what she
found was
this part of the Pacific the eastern
Pacific wasn't warm and moist it was
cool and dry unknown only that but the
periods of low rainfall in her coral
coincide exactly with prolonged droughts
in the American West
droughts in Central America which had a
profound effect on Maya civilization
droughts in the Andes droughts in
Australia and in Asia and for the first
time we can see that one of the great
villains of the Medieval Warm Period
wasn't El Nino
it was La Nina the cold opposite part of
La Nina and it seems very likely that
there were major impacts during the
Medieval Warm Period on all kinds of
civilizations
for example the Maya over a thousand
years the Maya Lords became astoundingly
expert at conserving water and their big
cities like Tikal here were also giant
water catchments with huge systems of
reservoirs which irrigated the land
around them and this water was very
carefully controlled by the nobles each
village had its own tanks but thanks to
deep-sea cause of Venezuela which
correlate beautifully with the Palmyra
call and with other calls in Asia we
know that a set of droughts often found
are also found in freshwater lakes in
the Yucatan so that Maya civilization
was jolted by long prolonged droughts at
the very moment when we know it
collapsed in a wide area the same is
true of Chan Chan the great she more
capital on the peruvian coast which
managed to survive because they had very
sophisticated irrigation tihuanaco upon
the islands in the other hand failed to
survive because all its investment was
in raised
pharming so a thousand years ago there
were huge droughts and the word ladies
and gentlemen is not drought its
prolonged drought in a world there were
many millions fewer people in our today
fast-forward to the 19th century in the
late nineteenth century there were a
series of massive El Nino events and
monsoon failures which impacted India at
the height of the British watch at a
time when India was exporting grain for
the world grain market millions of
people died you can see the pictures
here and it is estimated by one
historian and I see no reason at all to
doubt his estimate during the nineteenth
century are you ready for this between
20 and 30 million people perished as a
result of famine and famine related
diseases more than in virtually all wars
of the same century in a century when
the world's population at risk was a
fraction of that of today what the study
of climate change in the past does is to
use a very broad range of academic
disciplines on archaeology climatology
history even bugs all sorts of things to
look at what one French historian calls
the long delay because the point about
the past is that it doesn't tell us what
the future is going to be but it shapes
not only the future but the way we think
about it and one of the things that the
lesson of the Medieval Warm Period
should do and also the lesson of 19th
century famines should do is to alert us
to what I call the silent
Alif
in the climatic room there was a huge
lot of froth being talked and the
chatterers are having a wonderful time
talking about global warming higher
temperatures this Nizhny snips higher
sea levels but the silent elephant that
very few people talk about is dropped
the Hadley Center which is a highly
respected meteorological center in
England has recently done a computer
modeling project computer modeling is
showing people discuss and argue about
Lourdes and this study gives you a
perspective on the medieval droughts
I've talked about and I can only in a
short compass of time give you an
adequate picture there's been a 25%
increase in global drought since 1990 at
the moment only 3 percent of the world's
population suffers from extreme drought
many of them in the Sahara and Sahel and
there was a memorable quote in the paper
last week from somebody who was yakking
about oil in Chad and some formalin
leaders said we don't want our we won't
water when he was right that severe
drought will affect 40 percent of us up
from 8 and moderate drought half of
humanity look at those figures even if
they're half right there Franklin and I
wager that some of the major Wars of the
next centuries will be for naught over
petty nationalisms but over water
because in today's world I don't have
the exact figure but at least 300
million people are severely at risk for
drought and starvation and just like the
19th century many of us are totally
oblivious to it and the challenge of
global warming to me isn't frothing
about temperatures it's what the hell
are we going to do as a world community
about issues which are large like the
hidden elephant which we don't want to
think about we don't want to spend money
on which require
long-term thinking in the perspective of
grandchildren a great challenge rather
than the next election do we have the
will as human beings to do this I can
only tell you one thing from the long
perspective of the past is that humans
are generally very opportunistic
brilliant at adaptation and have
adjusted to incredibly difficult
conditions when there were many few of
us and some people say ah the technology
will do it today I sometimes wonder if
we're at the moment of truth because to
me the elephant in the room in a
long-term thinking without question one
of the major ones is drugged thank you
Thank You Bryan I think you will agree
with me that Bryan Fagan is an amazing
storyteller his books are equally
wonderful storytelling I must confess I
spent my childhood in Norway and grew up
on herring good for you it's a story I
would like to forget but I and I loved
parachutists versus truffle hunter so
just how many parachutists in the room
how many truffle hunters more
parachutists than truffle hunters so you
will see yeah if the truffle hunters
questions get answered as well
you said something at the very end I
want to actually begin with question
from me drought so one of the areas that
is likely to be affected well actually
before I get to the questions I think
all the questions by the way I might say
essentially all the questions all point
in the same direction what everybody
wants to know is what you think all this
means for today and tomorrow so that
every one of these questions in one way
or another which I answer what which
I've answered them yes well we'll
explore in a little more detail okay
well have a girl or so what are the
questions to my question what's that ooh
this other way yes in this occasion when
I gave a lecture with a jug of water on
the pond put vodka in it one of the
areas that is particularly vulnerable to
drought is the Tibetan Highlands and the
Tibetan Highlands provide the water for
the Indus the Ganges the Bama Putra the
Mekong the yellow and the Yangtze
approximately two and a half billion
people depend upon the waters of the
Tibetan Highlands and many of those
folks haven't liked each other much in
the past what risk do you see that the
kind of drought that you foresee will be
the trigger to the conflicts along the
Mekong along the Indus it's very high
indeed because you've got cases where
people now are damming the rivers and
that also is the environment you've got
the Nile where they're now diming and
to them and the government's that live
upstream control it and I think the the
the potential conflicts enormous it's
very frank and that's something we can't
do much about we're kind of reaching a
moment in history where the scale of
everything is so much larger and it's
almost overwhelming well actually that
brings us to one of the questions
Stephen Fleming where are you over here
so L Neil Smith whom I'm not sure who
that is do you know that is who's L Neil
Smith a historian and author said
considering all the consequences the
invention of agriculture may be the
worst mistake in human history what do
you think I don't think you can consider
it oddly enough a deliberate act the way
it seems to have come about and there's
been a on I'm an a KERS of literature is
that in areas where plant foods wild
plant foods became scarce ax during the
Younger Dryas drought or when
populations reached a certain critical
point you're talking carrying capacity
of the land people started to plant now
they didn't plant say I'm gonna become a
farmer they planted to get more food in
a logical extension because as I said
they want to preserve their life and
they made decisions in good faith to try
and preserve their life the long-term
consequences of which you couldn't
possibly tell it's rather like building
the Aswan Dam it was built and the
environmental consequences have been
simply horrible generations make
decisions in good faith within the
context of the life they're living and
that's what happened here the results I
agree are not necessarily a good thing
but let us not idealize the
hunter-gatherer life it was tough though
you know the argument has been made
recently that we would have entered an
ice age
three thousand years ago were it not for
Chinese discovery of terraced rice
agriculture and the process of the rice
hulls decaying producing methane
producing greenhouse gases and thereby
warming preventing the onset of another
I say have you been reading Ruddiman
Marie what reading a Ruddiman Ruddiman
yes he's very controversial there are
people who are detecting signs of
releases of fresh water in the North
Atlantic now right I kind of feel he
stretched that a bit I think it very
probably is the industrial revolution
which is the main one so Matthew McClure
asks where's Matthew hello Matthew he's
over there way back there oh yeah hi
Matthew so does your experience in
archeology and anthropology suggest
anything about the sustainable carrying
capacity the planet and its fragility in
the light of climate change why you ask
big questions don't you um you're taking
the long view yeah yes I really so far
over the long haul of history up to now
people have come up with solutions the
price in human life has been enormous I
think it really ultimately comes down
and I hate to come back to this to water
because water is the one thing we can't
control and I don't know if you've
recently been to Las Vegas or the Tucson
or the Phoenix it is truly frightening
let alone
Bakersfield we are living on borrowed
time and all you got do is go to Owens
Lake and see it and to me it comes down
to one word water and up to now human
societies of code how much longer can we
cope it sort of desalinization almost
all our research suggests that research
at gbn that the mechanism of
transmission of climate effects is water
whether it's hyper severe rains or
floods or rising sea level
in comes the motor it all comes down to
water and as populations grow more and
more people live in marginal lands so my
own so is it comes down to water it's a
good question so rate of change there's
lots of reason that you showed a chart
that shows the rate of change of climate
apparently accelerating what an autistic
yes yes and there's good reason to
believe that it may be increasing so how
does that relate to our rate of
adaptation our ability to adapt do we
have the ability to adapt at an
accelerating rate no I don't think we do
I think he's the range thing because
somewhere I'm Sayla and occasionally I
go sailing in small yachts and one of
the most memorable experiences I ever
had was to ship out on an 830 foot
container ship with the pilot out of the
Golden Gate for that boat to have
steerage way he has to sail at 12 knots
which is about 15 to 18 miles an hour
just be able maneuver and he could see a
quarter of a mile in front of the bow he
couldn't see anything because the ship
so high and a yacht sailed so close to
us we couldn't see it anymore
and I said to the pilot what are we
gonna do and he just looked at me and
said nothing there's nothing I can do
it'd take me two miles to stop this ship
we live in a large industrial cumbersome
civilization our ability to respond
rapidly to anything let alone to move
people which is one of the most
effective strategies for coping the
population guy okay compilation with
climate change has reduced drastically
just look I hate to bring it up at
Hurricane Katrina it's frightening it
will already seen the insurance
companies not being willing to write and
you can't blame them you cannot entirely
blame them and because if there's one
thing most global warming people I've
talked to agree on we're gonna see more
extreme weather events
and imagine the category-five hurricane
in the middle of Miami Beach
it isn't imagine it's gonna happen one
day maybe not in our lifetimes what's
gonna happen oh it might happen I think
well within our lifetimes but you know
what you talked about for example the
the example of the Peruvian society that
collapsed in a matter of days we've
talked about on the other hand parts of
European society that adapted in an
opportunistic way toward warming and
moved northwards and so on but now
you've talked about a fairly brittle
modern civilization how would you
compare our flexibility and AD
adaptability to earlier societies early
societies everybody that was a question
from Noah where's Noah Noah flower right
here it's it comes back again to the
question of the number of people on
earth both you and I are old enough to
remember a much emptier world about half
yeah and I remember and I go back
there's an obvious example going sailing
in the English Channel in August and
going to a harbor in the Channel Islands
and we were the only boat there I went
back in 1995 and there was no space and
we're in the same situation there's so
many of us now that we can't adapt
easily the most powerful lesson that's
come out of country no to me reading
superficially is the most powerful
weapon people have of their own friends
and relatives and in the final analysis
that what makes societies adapt
successfully and urban societies are so
anonymous that's very different hey babe
well now we're talking about moving on
from simply adapted adapting so this is
from Steven someone no last name like
bond Jane right yeah James Bond oh no
what is your view on human efforts to
attain attenuate climate change such as
the carbon drawdown or efforts to
sustain the thermohaline cycle are these
efforts futile who was that right there
Steven whoo Thank You Steven magazine I
hate to tell you I don't know I'm not
just an archaeologist I'm studying the
long view of climate change I frankly
have not kept up with what's going on my
impression is that anything that tried
should be tried and if it doesn't work
we move on the brahmma is a tank most
fascinating thing is the the well
impetus for a lot of this is coming from
government is not coming from
governments it's coming from business
which is the way it's going to happen I
don't think we've got the political will
we are looking at the next election
rather than looking 100 years down the
line I'm not optimistic a lot of these
questions just not my thing
yes well here's a historical question
given your example of how it took a
strict provincial leadership for Egypt
to survive are we going to need a strict
father here I once talked about ancient
emergencies believe it or not to a
conference of emergency preparedness
technicians just after Katrina and the
presentation after mine was by a group
of people who'd been down there and they
showed the pictures and these included
corpses never think it was very
harrowing and I said I told them this
example and I said the most important
thing is very resolutely leadership at
the local level and at the top and there
were loud applause and cheers this
audience was an angry audience not with
me and I just said ladies and gentlemen
you thought it I thought it but I didn't
say it because one lesson you learn from
Egypt and you learn from a lot of these
things that the people who really are
good at leadership in situations like
this are the people who are in touch
with the local communities who have a
relatives in the local communities who
really know what makes them function and
that was the lesson of Egypt and the
pharaohs were useless the later Pharaohs
different matter they really invested in
storage they invest in irrigation and
they changed the ideology from being the
supreme God who was infallible to being
shepherds of the people and they learned
we've got a lot to learn about it so so
do we need to plan for the seven lean
years and we need to be putting up our
supplies for that it isn't us it's them
and the point is we ignore them who's
them the people living in marginal lands
people living in drought prone lands the
developing world that's where the
problem is going to be and you're going
to get issues of migration involuntary
migration you're almost gonna get
migration walls you can get that bad
you're talking about enormous numbers of
people and most people's consciousness
of this and believe me I'm not preaching
it's Jarrell well in fact our research
there you take a look at places like
Haiti whose ecosystems are already
shattered parts of Central America
similarly and they get hit with mega
droughts or ultra severe storms and we
are going to have large numbers of
people washing up on our shores
Bangladesh sea level gets hit with big
monsoons and you're gonna have a hundred
million Bangladeshis coming to visit
pact as India and China and not
particularly welcome and the Sahel is
the classic oh yeah I mean you're
talking things that frighten the hell
out of me so Kevin Kelly wants to know
our own Kevin I assume that's you Kevin
right okay
in periods of large-scale prolonged
drought where does the water go does it
always mean that it's you know if it's
warm and dry somewhere it's going to be
cold and wet somewhere else or is there
always a balancing out somewhere in the
world not necessarily no no if you look
at the our global effects of El Ninos
classically major El Nino says drought
in Southeast Asia Indonesia the Strout
in Northeast Brazil is drought in
Central America who gets more rain we
get more rain it's patchy but generally
it the biggest impact is drought so this
is the last question it's the bottom
line question you have children you have
children I have two - okay
you may even have grandchildren soon me
don't know is it soon so I have known a
long way one of my daughters actually
lives in San Francisco well in any event
if you were gonna ask if if you're gonna
tell advise your children your
grandchildren where to live you've told
us we're gonna move where should they go
live I don't know an interesting
question on that the Midwest problem now
I have no idea
probably Canada probably can't it's
gonna get nice and warmer Canada has a
much more civilized views on a lot of
things in society in here and actually
if there's warming Canada will benefit
this will get drier that'll get better
we have a beachfront property on
Hudson's Bay that's right so we'll take
our vacations together on Hudson's Bay
in the middle of the next century
thank you Brian Fagan
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you